Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to clone real human voices
using an AI. How? Well, in an earlier NVIDIA
keynote, we had a look at Jensen Jr., an
AI-powered virtual assistant of NVIDIA’s CEO,
Jensen Huang. It could do, this! Look
at the face of that proud man! I love
how it also uses hand gestures that
go really well with the explanation.
These virtual AI assistants are going to appear
everywhere to help you with your daily tasks.
For instance, in your car, the promise
is that they will be able to recognize
you as the owner of the car, recommend
shows nearby, and even drive you there.
These Omniverse avatars may also help us order our
favorite burgers too. And, we won’t even need to
push buttons on a touchscreen. We just need to
say what we wish to eat and the assistant will
answer and take our orders, perhaps later even
in a familiar person’s voice. How cool is that?
And today, I am going to ask you to imagine a
future where we can all have our Toy Jensens
or our own virtual assistants with our own
voice. All of us! That sounds really cool! So,
is that in the far future? No-no, not at all!
Today, I have the amazing opportunity to show
you a bit more about the AI that makes
this voice synthesis happen. And yes,
you will hear things that are only
available here at Two Minute Papers.
So, what is all this about? This work is an
AI-based technique that takes samples of our
voice, and can then clone it. So, let’s give it a
try. This is Jamil from NVIDIA who was kind enough
to record these voice snippets. Listen. Okay, so
how much of this do we need to train the AI? Well,
not the entire life recordings of the test
subject, but much less, 30 minutes of these
voice samples. The technique asks us to say
these sentences and analyzes the timbre,
prosody and the rhythm of our voice, which is
quite a task. And, what can it do afterwards?
Well, hold on to your papers, because Jamil,
not the real one, the cloned AI Jamil has
a scholarly message for you that I wrote.
Now, of course, it is not perfect, I think
that most of you are able to tell that these
voice lines were synthesized, but my opinion is
that these are easily good enough for a helpful
humanlike virtual assistant. And, really, how cool
is that? Cloning a human voice from half an hour
worth of sound samples. What a time to be alive!
And note that I have been really tough with them,
these are some long, scholarly sentences that
would give a challenge to any of these algorithms.
Now, if you are one of our earlier Fellow
Scholars, you might remember that a few years ago,
we talked about an AI technique called Tacotron,
which can perform voice cloning from a really
short, few second-long sample. I have only heard
examples of simpler, shorter sentences for that,
and what is new here is that this new
technique takes more data, but in return,
offers higher quality. But it does not stop there!
It does more! This new method is easier to train
and it also generalizes to more languages better.
And these are already good enough to be used in
real products, so I wonder what a technique like
this will look like just two more papers down the
line. Maybe my voice here on Two Minute Papers
could be synthesized by an AI? Maybe it already
is? Would that be a good thing? What do you think?
Also, a virtual Károly for you to read your daily
dose of papers? Actually, since NVIDIA has a great
track record of putting these amazing tools into
everyone’s hands, if you are interested, there
is already an early access program where you can
apply. I hope that some of you will be able to
try this and let us know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!